[Music]
on today's show we talked to a mom who's
been divorced but she's trying to teach
her sons that marriage can be good we
also talk to another divorced mom whose
ex-husband is being a jerk to her sons
and she doesn't know what to do
and finally we talk to a woman who's
trying to create a life where she
doesn't need to drink to get through it
stay tuned
[Music]
what's up what's up this is john with
the dr john deloney show i hope you're
doing so good and hope your family's
well
everybody's healthy
school is back in action whatever that
means for you and your family i'm trying
to figure out what that means for me and
my family
james kelly you all back in
uh my kids went today my baby started
high school is that why you're smiling
from year to year like
oh they're back
my little one went to high school today
so it's kind of hard yeah is that a tear
i see no
no no
james but yeah my kids started school
homeschool but they started school today
too
that's pretty cool it's very cool i
appreciate you holding him on the same
schedule
i don't even know why i appreciate that
but
it's like a strange thing to appreciate
so in the spirit of learning
we're going to do a little lesson today
about time zones
because
we've all noticed and the callers have
noticed that you
uh seem to have a wildly inaccurate
grasp of time zones when you
you call someone
in our same time zone or maybe even
an earlier time zone you're like man
sorry it must be super early there and
it's like the same time as here or
or like one hour like people think we
record our show like in bermuda you know
or something but sometimes we're
recording at 8 30 and then somebody
calls from los angeles
but usually it's like michigan which is
actually yeah eastern time
i was looking at an old call or
listening to an old call just the other
day and this happened you said it must
be the middle of the night for you and
she said it's 8 30.
listen
no so to help you out look look to to
the right of the trash can i have a
little i have a little note for you
there
a little cheat sheet if you will
there you go
it's a time zone chart we can just keep
it on your desk now that that assumes he
knows the states
they're labeled on the sheets
alaska arizona arkansas do you know
where they are yes i used to be a
geography teacher
doesn't mean a lot doesn't mean
can i tell you a great story about that
so first day of school and my first day
of school i mean day one it's awesome
the kids are coming in and i'm greeting
them i'm this 21 year old coach
not the smartest guy in the world
clearly
and
one kid comes in and i ask him his name
and he's really kind he's got a unique
name and i say hey where's where's that
name what's the origin of that name
where are you from and he said sri lanka
and i said
that's fantastic where is sri lanka in
just one of my punk students just goes
ain't you the geography teacher and i
was like oh no you're exactly right i
didn't know where sri lanka was and so i
really had to had to put the time in
wasn't great not one of my uh proudest
professional moments
much like uh we're getting up on the
one-year anniversary and we did some
like in review for an upcoming episode
after about the third one of the old
shows i watched i for real started
looking for jobs on the internet like i
used ken coleman's career finder and uh
i just don't think this is the right
thing for me guys you've grown a lot in
the last year listen
we'll save it for that episode all i can
say is whoa all right well
thank you
geography bullies is what you're
supposed to say now when anyone calls
you out on something that you're a dumb
at you're supposed to like act sad and
like you hurt my feelings
i'm just going to quit commenting on
time zones how about that
no i think it's great i disagree
so we just had people be really confused
like when you when do you guys record
your show
this is why people think we record when
i call them they think you know oh we
record on saturdays or i sent something
to somebody the other day i said at four
o'clock and she said am so this is why
people think that
well
with that
rudeness we're gonna go to susan in
nashville susan it must be the middle of
the night there in nashville how are you
i'm doing well how are you i'm good and
i'm in nashville too i realize we're on
the exact same time
yes uh hey it's what it's 2 30 in the
morning so thanks for being up so late
with us i just spoke up thank you so
much you are a trooper and america's
grateful and by america there's like 41
people listening to this thing so it's
just us a couple of folks in the booth
and some of our neighbors but what is up
how can i help
um i was calling because i was divorced
about five years ago after 26 years of
marriage and we had three children
um
and my youngest two children really only
knew a bad marriage in a you know bad
environment because of my ex-husband's
drinking which led to verbal abuse
during those periods
and i
don't really
think they have a high opinion of
marriage and while i am divorced i still
believe in the concept of marriage and
my youngest head said the other day he
said well i'm never going to get married
because all marriages end in divorce and
it just kind of crushed me yeah and i
just didn't you know and i tried to talk
to him about it but
he didn't say much and i was just
wondering you know what i can do to
tell them i still
even though it didn't work out for me i
still want that for them
that's a very unique question what a
cool
conversation to enter in with your boys
how old are they
um the youngest is 16 and then i have a
20 year old and a 24 year old okay and
are you close with them do you all
talk yes okay that's really cool good
for you
how's the last five or six years been
for you hard uh a relief both what's it
been like every it's been it was such a
relief it's extremely hard i'm working
multiple jobs um
but
it is um we're all in such a better
place it's it's it's so much every day
i'm grateful that's so good do you still
have a relationship with your ex-husband
no no
is he still connected to his boys
um
i think he might try but he lives away
now
you know he was an incredible father to
my oldest he wasn't incredible you know
everything you would think a father
should be and then you know the drinking
really took him to a dark place and i
think my my younger to
see know that he was he was good and you
know we talked about the addiction and
you know how that changed the person and
changed him and
um
i'm honest with that but
you know i just i mean and i you know
they don't talk a lot about emotions and
feelings they're boys
but i will relate to them because i know
it'll
get to them you know deep down and
hopefully they'll hear their mother talk
to them but i just was i was so crushed
when he said that he was like i'm not
gonna get married you know they all
ended in divorce i was like oh no they
don't
so
i want to
push on something and then we can talk
through what we can do next okay
first is the idea that boys don't talk
about their feelings is often
if not entirely because they don't have
men in their lives modeling what talking
about feelings looks like
and what they desperately need all boys
do
every single one of them on the planet
needs to understand that
the emotions and feelings in their
bodies are theirs and they've got to
take ownership of them and then go make
good relational decisions on the back
end and so
what you could give them
which would be a gift beyond gift beyond
gift
is teaching them
what are you feeling right now what does
that feel like tell me what where that
is in your body
and help them connect oh i'm not this
thing like we say i'm angry no you're
not you're feeling this way
um i'm really pissed off right now you
as your identity is not you feel this
way and once you can
put a gap between yourself and your
feeling a gap between yourself and your
thought
then you're talking about legacy change
that's a life change because then i can
make decisions right when i think i am
then that stuff owns me it is me when i
can separate myself from it and go oh
that guy just cut me off i'm feeling
really raged out against that dude right
now
and i'm gonna choose to keep driving the
speed limit because i'm not an idiot
right so you can pick in between there
so a great great thing you could do for
those boys would be to have
conversations about what feelings feels
like
and give them words to the things going
on in their bodies
what a gift that would be so that's just
an aside um
so let me ask you why are you high on
marriage why is it good
probably the way i was raised um you
know i just it's you know
it's just something
that should happen if you're in love
with somebody and you know it can be a
good thing so i thank you if you were
trying to sell me on being married
you just did not pass that test
i would have
i would have given you an f season yes
so okay thank you
hey you know what that's what we're
doing we're lifting spirits on this show
tell me why you believe in marriage
why do you want that why do you want
that for your boys
i'm probably more of a religious i think
it's a sacrament you know and i mean i
believe in
that you know you should if you want to
spend because you i don't want them to
be alone i guess and you know if you
have a life partner
i think a life partner means more if
you're married and if you're just
living together okay
because you know you can experience
life with them you can't do that if
you're just i mean
it's a mind it's more of a contract more
of a spiritual thing i think if you're
married okay
so here's what i want to push on you on
i want you to get really clear with why
you're high on marriage
and one of the challenges for adults and
i'm included in this
that we are facing that
no no generation of parents adults in
the history of earth has had to deal
with
is
kids who are in mass getting information
from a thousand different places
right
up until recently they could possibly
get them from their you know a book the
last 50 years but before that they got
it from their parents
maybe a friend or two in the neighboring
farming community
and some sort of church leader that's
about it
right
now
they can google anything
they've got access to millions of
like-minded or same-aged people all over
the earth and so they're getting
different information and they're asking
different questions which i love
the idea that quote-unquote you're just
supposed to
is not good enough for today's 16 to 24
year olds
that answer doesn't doesn't pass muster
the
it would just be better if you did
they're going to ask why because the
data they're able to see that other
generations weren't able to see is
one attitude doesn't work
and the one that i saw that was working
isn't great
now i like you am super high on it
i'm a big fan of marriage big time
but i've spent years trying to really
drill down why it's important to me and
why it is backed up with science and
spirituality and connection and
relationship and all those things
but i don't think you can articulate it
well enough to pass it on to them
is that fair
yeah
so
i think a gift for them would be you
saying i really love this and i'm trying
to figure out why because it hurt me and
it hurt us and let them hear your
process
and then commit hey we're going to get a
book on marriage and
i want you all to read it with me and
we're going to talk about it
letting them see you on a journey will
be one of the greatest gifts ever my mom
went back to school in her 40s
it was such a blessing at 16 17 22 it
drove us crazy because she'd come
running in and reading some
shakespeare's sonnet and we'd all be
like oh come on she'd get in front of
the game we were watching
and read something in middle english and
she'd be laughing and we were like what
are you doing
now though i can see all these years
later i was watching my mom
model for me what change in your mind
looks like what getting new information
looks like what having a strong belief
and then expanding that looks like being
able to articulate an argument looks
like
and that's one of the greatest gifts of
my life that i'm trying to pass on to my
children
and so yeah 16 year old hey we're gonna
read a book on marriage he's gonna roll
his eyes so far out the back of his head
he's gonna be blind right
and your 24 year old's gonna say mom
we're not we're not doing that
but i think your boys love you and
they'd go with you on this especially if
you went and got some like a good
book that they could understand
um
and
go on that journey with them but you've
got to be able to articulate why this is
important to them
before you can sell them on it because
all they have
besides the data and besides their
buddies
you know their parents are all divorced
too
all they have is the hurt in their
hearts from what they experienced
and their idea of marriage is connected
to their feelings about dad and their
feelings about mom
and so what you've got to do is help
them get a gap between those feelings
identify them
feel them and then say here's why
marriage is important
and i think this is going to be a
lifelong adventure for you
but i think it's worthy and it's noble
to get in and get after it
and so i'll just high five you good for
you here's what i want you to do please
call me back and let me know how it goes
um
when you sit down and say hey we're
gonna read this together and maybe it's
not a book maybe it's a article maybe
it's an article maybe it's um connecting
them with
a guy who's you know like a coach or
somebody that you know or somebody in
the church something like that that's
been married a long long time and he can
articulate it
really clearly right or he can come over
or the couple can come over and talk to
you guys about it
but it's about being awkward it's about
being intentional it's about being
vulnerable it's about getting right in
the middle of saying what you know and
what you don't know
and i think it's good yeah it's gonna be
a lifelong adventure for you guys but i
applaud the effort i really really do
and i applaud you leaning into something
that hurt you that was hard for you and
saying that doesn't mean the whole
thing's wrong that doesn't mean we throw
the whole thing out just because i was
on the receiving end of pain
i think that takes boldness and bravery
and good for you susan good good for you
all right let's go to jennifer in
phoenix hey jennifer what's going on
hi i'm good how are you i'm fantastic
man it must be the i'm just kidding how
are you
i'm pretty good good it's just a regular
time wherever you are so that's great
just a regular old time james and kelly
were making fun of me earlier about how
to read a clock and i'm not very good at
it so now i'm just uh i'm trying to
defend i'm trying to make jokes out of
my discomfort that's what i'm doing so
sorry jennifer you're walking into like
a room and everyone's laughing and
you're like oh what's going on so sorry
i just did that to you so what's up
well um
yeah i bet you it's pretty earlier but
thank you for taking my question of
course
i've been divorced
from my ex-husband for 10 years now
um and i have two little boys and
it's
um
it's just been a struggle because
there's it's two different households
with different ideas of
how to do things and now that they're
starting to
get older and ask questions and notice
things they are
being faced with some difficult
subject matter and also just
trying to decide
who's telling the truth and
um
just things that you know a 10 year old
and 12 year old shouldn't have to to
deal with and
you know as a parent i
thought you know after years that
i would be past all this stuff i guess
oh you're just starting jennifer you're
just starting i'm so sorry oh man
oh i just i don't i don't want things to
be difficult for them but i'm noticing
patterns it's like i've kept things very
business-like between
the relationship between their dad and i
just to avoid conflict
um
but now that they're starting to get
older they're starting to get caught in
the middle of all that yeah
so your boys are worth conflict if
they're not safe
and your boys are worth the conflict
that's what parents are for
is to go between them and
pain right that's what parents do
so something must have happened recently
or a couple of things happen what have
you experienced recently that's
precipitating this call
well it's just it's
little things over the years that are
constant so i'm hearing from them about
fighting going on at their dad's house
and you know i try not to get involved
in all that stuff because i don't know
what the situation is over there
and i don't want to talk bad about their
dad
because i want them to have a
relationship with their dad but it's
comments that i know that are hurtful
with them
um i like saying all the the only reason
that i married your mom was to have kids
like why would she say that
um and and just little things over the
years um
making
negative comments about me
things that make them question their
themselves and their
intelligence um
you know they're just
being called you know awful names and
give me an example i don't
like my my older son he was diagnosed as
a
young child with adhd and i really
believe that's just a result of all the
turmoil from this situation
but he's been called stupid and been
told his brain doesn't work
um
and i just i don't think that's helpful
no you can't do that with your kids
you absolutely can't deal with their
kids yeah
so you know you mentioned a second ago
that there's fighting going on there
what do you mean by that
yelling people getting pushed around
what do you mean by that
nasty yelling and screaming um i don't
think it turned to physical things but
um i know he's you know broken things in
the house
with him there go
with him there and i know that
for me
i know that that's not okay
but
legally
that's not enough which is sad how do
you know have you gone and asked
yes i have and some and an attorney told
you no that your their dad can call them
stupid until their brains broken and
smash stuff and scream at them and
that's okay well the problem is is that
it's
hard for me to prove that and when i
talk to the boys they don't
they don't
want to tell me the whole story a lot of
times so i'll notice that they're upset
and i'll ask
um but they're very reflecting because
they don't want to get their dad in
trouble and i've always told them like
hey you know i'm never gonna
judge you or whatever we can talk about
anything so we have a very you know
established open communication and they
know that
i'm just here to support them you know
and whether it's school or activities or
even stuff with their dad
so let's let's back out for for 30 000
feet okay
yeah let's say you guys were at a park
and
a mom showed up with her kid and they
were playing
and your son was climbing up this the
ladder to go down a slide
and she ran up to him and got in his
face
and started saying what are you stupid
what are you an idiot you're stupid
brain broken there was another kid in
line and he said i'm sorry ma'am i'm
sorry and he started climbing down and
she's like just stay there you stupid
idiot what would you do
oh i would
we would leave obviously i wouldn't
allow him to to
receive that kind of but i would you
know have some things to say to that
that person
so here's the thing your boys are
learning have learned to protect their
dad from you
because you've been protecting him for a
decade since your divorce
you know they're not safe over there
you know what they're living in is
wild
and you've even said things to me like i
don't want to get involved
i don't want i want them to be able to
be around their dad that's important
and so in doing so you've created a
fantasy that you're trying to uphold
you're trying to keep duct tape together
and the boys are on the other end of
this
and they've watched well it must be okay
um i must need to go over here
and this must just be part of fill in
the blank
and so is their mom
in a situation that you would not allow
with a stranger
they desperately need you to get
involved
desperately
and if that means taking them to a play
therapist who can talk with them get
them to tell them her or him things that
they wouldn't tell you great
if that's a school counselor great
if that's you calling him saying if you
call my kids stupid again we'll go to
court and i may lose but i'm then we're
going to go again and then we're going
to go again
because i'm not going to let people call
my kids stupid tell me of a broken brain
i'm not going to let somebody smash
stuff and make my 10 year old feel so
terrified in the home of someone who's
supposed to love him and keep him safe
i'm not
i guess i'm just concerned that
if i start pushing on this again which
has been my experience in the past that
it's just going to make it worse
um
which is something that you know as
their mom i am
worried about what do you mean you're
gonna make it worse
it would just make it more
stressful for them over there that they
would get in trouble
um
do you hear what you're saying
yes thank you
yeah they need you
now more than ever
and
if they get in more trouble
i mean i hear what you're saying and
that fear is real i don't want to
minimize your fear
but what i'm trying to tell you is
you're their mom
and if
by calling him and saying are you do not
call our son stupid he's not
i know there's a business arrangement
all that it's got to become a a
relational arrangement y'all are in this
forever together
right right
is he able to have a conversation with
you about this
like if you called him and said hey man
they're telling me that you tell them
that they're stupid
will he take it out on them
yeah what does that mean will he yell at
him further will he say what could be if
you told your mom on me and all that
kind of nonsense
yeah all of that
i think you got to sit down with an
attorney asap
because your boys aren't safe
and the attorney may tell you i'm so
sorry i can't do anything about this i
just don't think that's right
i do think your boys could go get an
eval
and
it's my guess is there's other stuff
going on there
do you would you believe that too
i would suspect yeah okay
go with your gut
because right now what your boys are
learning is some people are just mean
and crazy and we just put up with it
and if nothing else if nothing else
at least two years five years seven
years from now
there will be a track record that you
can show your boys and say i went to war
for you guys i lost every time but i
never gave up fighting for y'all
and it is okay
i tell people 24 7 365 don't talk bad
about your ex i believe that
wholeheartedly
but if one of your boys gets told
they're stupid you hold their face and
you look them in the eye and say that is
not right
and i know that your daddy loves you but
you are not stupid he should not have
said that
he is wrong
they've got to have somebody in their
life speaking truth into him a different
way and there's got to be a physical
aspect to that it will help a young
child to help him absorb it okay
your kids at 10 and 12 are going to get
enough mixed messages at school
on the internet they're going to get it
everywhere they've got to have some
stability and they cannot have parents
who are smashing stuff throwing temper
tantrums screaming at them threatening
them
you can't do that
they are learning right now that this is
how you treat your children
and so the longer it goes before there's
some intervention from an adult who
cares about them the longer it gets
embedded in them that this is how dads
treat their kids
and this is how generational trauma goes
on and on and on
and i hate hate hate that you're the one
stuck in the middle of this i really do
and you're their mom
you're their mom
so today
today i'm on the phone with the lawyer
today i'm on the phone with school
counselor
today i'm on the phone with a play
therapist in the area that your school
counselor can recommend you
go talk to
your boys will talk
they'll tell somebody even if it's not
you
and get them with the right professional
care and then you find out your options
okay and if you find out if you i want
to be i want to be as
realistic as possible if you find out
hey i'm so sorry there's nothing here
dads are allowed to scream and smash
stuff in front of their kids they're
allowed to call their son stupid they're
allowed to tell their son's
biological lies that their brains are
broken or whatever
you've got to be hyper hyper intentional
about making sure those boys know when
they come to your house they're safe
that they are not stupid their brains
are not broken daddy is not telling you
the truth and it's okay to combat lies
it really is it's a difference between
your dad's a liar
it's different say your daddy is wrong
he is wrong and i'm sorry
and they you you're playing a long long
game now you're playing a 5 10 15 20
year game where you're gonna try to
rescue your boys from an abusive dad
and my gut tells me the older they get
the bigger they get the more
they grow into
a male a man body
that aggression going gonna get more and
more and more
and that means the earlier you can
squash this the better
the earlier earlier earlier go to bat
form man they need you
they need you need you jennifer
ugh i hate that
guys
husbands we need you man we need you
more than ever
gotta have your husbands
dad's gotta have it we'll be right back
on the doctor john de luna show
you always hear me talking about how
good deep sleep impacts your anxiety
your depression your attitude your
mental health your physical health your
work performance sleep is critical to
every single thing in your life and if
you want to change the way you sleep you
first start with a world class mattress
one that you can actually afford and you
know i only recommend things that me and
my family use in our home and that's why
i partnered with dream cloud mattress
dream cloud gives you premium
world-class materials in a mattress at
half the price they utilize innovative
sleep signs to build mattresses that
keep you cool that support you in any
position and it adapts to your body i
made sure they have price points for
every budget dreamcloud is for you they
are currently running their biggest
offer ever a total of 650 bucks in
betting and cash savings exclusive for
dr john dolone's show listeners they
also have a 365 day home trial sleep on
it for a year and if you don't like it
send it back visit
dreamcloudsleep.com get 650 in savings
and goodies and start sleeping today
all right let's take one more call let's
go to heather in chicago hey heather
what's going on
hi dr john how are you i'm so good how
about you
i'm good i'm good outstanding how can i
help
um i just was wondering how i can
be fun again without alcohol
oh my goodness what a question
dig into that for me how can i be fun
again without alcohol
yes so um i am
i'm
i
am trying to learn i've stopped i've not
completely stopped drinking alcohol
but i don't drink as much as i used to
and
what happened that made you stop
i just didn't like um how i was i didn't
i didn't do
too much i don't think but even i
started drinking more like i'd have a
glass
of wine while i was making dinner and
then
it turned into two and then it turned
into three
and i wasn't sleeping well and i just
i'm trying to just better myself and
um
i'd also go out in social situations and
just have way too much okay to drink and
i feel like
it made me fun
and now i feel like when i go out i'll
have a drink or two when i go out with
friends but i don't feel like i'm fun
anymore
so what made that make sense oh
absolutely what made you fun
what did alcohol give you and talking to
the phone just directly this is really
important i don't want to miss this
what what made you fun
um
i guess just being more outgoing
and
i don't know just
able to open up more i guess these
people
and
just be more
outgoing i guess i don't know
and so now you go out and you realize
i don't even like these people
or you go out and realize i'd rather be
at home by myself watching netflix or
i'd rather be home yeah
doing other things than this
yeah
yeah be with my family yeah
i'd rather be with my family than with
you idiots
how old are you
i am 38. 38. man
so we can go down a rabbit hole on this
one and i'm so i could do a whole show
on this i could do two shows on this
um
and there's a couple of great books out
on this right now
um that i just i mean literally this
weekend i just
ran across one
okay in a nutshell
oh man she's always weak
this is such a big thread once you start
pulling untangling it
here's the deal you weren't fun
you weren't having fun
right what alcohol allows you to do is
to numb everything out
and it allowed you to be in a situation
that you didn't want to be in doing
things that you didn't want to do
and it allowed you to get past that
voice in your head saying won't just go
home this is stupid
because you possibly didn't like the
loud you didn't like
the hooking up you didn't like the jokes
you didn't like the just talk whatever
we were talking about whatever it is
alcohol you thought was making it more
fun for you
it took that away and then at home
my guess is you found yourself being
with your family but there's something
about it that is stressful is exhausting
is
high expectations you don't think you're
achieving whatever
and then all of a sudden you find
yourself
present with your family
physically but absolutely not present
emotionally and spiritually and
psychologically is that fair
yeah
so what about being at home
what about being with your friends
isn't enough
what is it about being with your family
being with your friends that you feel
like you've got to
put a pillow over those feelings
um
gosh that's a good question
i'm not sure
what i will tell you is the research is
telling us
here's what we're seeing right so
men for eternity have run everything
right and we know this they have the
most money they've got the most space
whatever
they also drink a lot right
this is a global phenomenon all over
earth
and they lead the planet in strokes
heart attacks cancers etc
and what they're calling it is diseases
of despair they've worked and achieved
themselves to death now i work a lot i
love what i do
i like achievement i like competition
what i've had to spend the last decade
doing is divorcing my identity from
those things
right those are things that i do not
things that i am right
okay and so
when i step back and look at alcohol has
allowed
power people in power to keep going
as does cocaine as does any number of
distraction addictions anger rage a new
girlfriend a new girlfriend a new wife a
new car a new whatever right
it allows you just to keep going and
keep going and keep going because the
signals in our bodies that say are we
enjoying this is this actually where we
want to be you can shut those signals
off
right that's what alcohol does
and what we've seen over the last 25
years
is
oh man
we're seeing a
in mass
women
becoming like these glass ceilings are
shattering and women are working hard
and they're there and they're crushing
it and they're doing so good and they're
being told hey by the way you have to be
the ceo and be a present mom and be at
home and do all these things and make
sure this is done and this is done and
this is done
and so the the game got bait and
switched on you and they got bait and
switched on
on male partners too everyone's in the
middle of a big bait and switch and what
we're seeing on an almost vertical trend
line
is
women are starting to catch up with
heart issues and cancer issues their
bodies are starting to to wait to wear
this too
and then you see the alcohol
relationship and it's almost a vertical
trend line and now you can't go to
target without
the shirts that say like you know
my my wine my sippy cup is a wine glass
or whatever you know those little cute
sayings and all that stuff right
it's become super normed
and instead of being heartbroken we're
all cheering about it
and here's what's happening
women
this is not a controversial statement by
and large women are smarter than men and
they um
are more connected more grounded than
men are this is just a generalized
statement you can put mean things in the
in the youtube comments whatever
and i think sooner they are recognizing
whoa this is not what i signed up for
like you mentioned i don't like
myself at home i don't feel good i don't
sleep good
um i'm out when i i'm out at the bar and
these people are idiots i don't have fun
right so the question you have to ask
yourself is
how do you build a life
how do you build a life that you don't
need to numb from
that you don't need to run from
what does that look like can you
articulate that for me
um
what conversations are you not having at
home
that you need to numb out from
what conversations
do you have to have with yourself about
hey these used to be my friends they're
just not anymore we're just different
now yeah like what are those
conversations that you need to have with
you and with your husband with people in
your life
well i know at home i feel
like really overwhelmed and
um
like i'm pretty much just
the only adult doing the things around
the house and taking care of the kids
and all of that so is your husband just
abandoning you on this have you all
talked about no um
we haven't like i haven't really just
got down and talked to him about it but
um he's pleasant he's pleasant he just
he's faster
and so when he comes home
it's just not
there's not a whole lot of help but
i don't know do you want to
i don't okay i don't
nope
so you are trapped in a guilt cycle that
says he's out working so i should be
doing all this stuff
and his job is this and my job is that
and
your job is weighing on you heavy
and you don't feel like you're good
enough at it and so like a good man
you're drinking the end of the day away
because your job's hard and you don't
ask for help
yep congratulations you're pretty much
you pretty much 100 hit it on the head
with i don't feel like i'm good enough
yeah you are i
you are
okay but then how do you in a social
situation
everyone else is
like drinking i don't want to it's not
i'm i'm good at stopping but then i feel
like i'm just
here's the hardest thing in the world
about stopping drinking i think this is
me
is you've got to change social circles
yeah and when you stop drinking
people around you either a
want to keep going and you ruin that for
them that's what they tell themself
or they feel
indicted by your behavior change
they know they'd like to quit too and
they can't
they know they want to make some life
changes and they can't
and so i think this is just me i want
any data to back this up or anything i
think the hardest thing about making any
major life change like this same with if
you want to change your diet you want to
lose a bunch of way and start eating
healthier
um those folks that you always went out
with every all the time
you quit going
or you're that guy at the you know the
chinese food place that brings you lunch
you don't want to be her right so you
just don't go
or you show up and you're eating carrots
and then people are going to make fun of
you because
they are indicted about what they're
eating same with alcohol
the hardest part of here is you have to
step back and say are these people still
my friends
and if you cannot have a connected
conversation with somebody without a
drink they are not your friend
okay
and i hate to say that like that
yeah what your husband
deserves
is you being honest about where you are
in your heart in your head because
here's the thing he feels it
in whatever way he's
he's numbing too
and i don't know how that's another
phone call my guess is you know how
yeah or you have your suspicions hal but
he's numbing too because he misses you
also
and so what we have is we have
a generation of women trying to do the
world
try to trying to enter trying to
interact and say that way with a
generation of women trying to interact
with the world
on its own power structure
that's killing everybody
and we have a group of men who are
saying i don't want this anymore but i
don't have any models any pictures i
don't have any way to get from here to
there i don't even know what there is
and that's when
whether it's you y'all have a great
relationship or you need to go talk to a
marriage counselor together to help
somebody have this conversation with you
and by the way me and my wife have this
conversation
on a regular basis
so
perfection doesn't mean you arrive
perfection means you practice this right
it's kind of like a a workout i can't
just work out once and call it i'm in
shape for the rest of my life i got to
keep going right so this whole thing is
constantly evolving and how old are your
kids
12
7 and 10. okay so your whole world is
just a blender right
and yeah when one of them turns 15 and
one of them right this is just going to
keep happening things are going to keep
shifting
and then you're gonna have two in middle
school and one in high school and then
one going to college one mil all this is
going to keep shifting shifting shifting
which means you're all going to have you
and your husband have to come up with a
not a solution forever
but a way that we we have we create new
solutions along the way you have to
create new train tracks for your train
to go on
okay but you're gonna have to look in
the mirror and say i'm good
that's hard i know it
is the whole world's telling you you're
not enough
that you should be at work you should be
doing this your house should look like
that your boys should never say these
things and they should be
all of it there's an entire world
telling you that you're not enough and
for whatever it's worth there's an
entire world telling him he's not enough
either
and so it's two people who committed to
ride or die together forever
looking at each other going you know
what you're good and i'm good
we can do better than this and we can do
it together
what do you need
how can i honor you in this right how do
i turn the offs offs and the ons on
and you telling him i've got to build
life here that i don't need to numb out
from
and i'm drinking too much
i'm drinking period i don't feel good i
don't like it i don't like who i am
after drink three
i don't like my kids
if they asked if i asked my kids to draw
a picture of me it would have me with a
wine glass i don't like any of that
stuff
yeah
and here's the thing you want to get
back to being quote unquote fun
turn music up in your house and dance so
you can't dance make your boys have
dance-offs with you
yeah plan romantic getaways or fun
intimate time with your husband you'll
decide and if it's awkward lean into the
awkward and invite him along with that i
don't know who you used to be
before your world became something that
you had to hide from
that's the adventure that you and your
husband can go on together
what did that look like and you're going
to find things that you have so deeply
buried that you're going to probably
spend some time with a professional
counselor to unbury those things to dig
them up
that's fair that's part of it
but don't oh my gosh
uh i started tracking my sleep and i've
almost entirely limited alcohol of
everything
even
tiny social cert it i
it messes my sleep up it's a poison it's
just bad for you okay
there's a lot of good books out right
now on this stuff
um we're seeing a gentle turn away from
alcohol at the same time we're seeing
alcohol consumption among women at a
just a
rocket ship pace
and
um all sort of all sort of addiction
numbers are all through the roof after
you know years of cove and all that
stuff
don't
build a life you don't have to hide from
i'll just leave it at that i keep saying
this over and over and maybe we'll do a
whole show on alcohol it's a whole thing
man you're better than this you're
better than this you're better than this
if you are listening to this and you
think whoa whoa whoa i'm down a road
that i don't want to be down
get with somebody immediately somebody
you trust
and begin asking those hard questions
ugh thank you so so much for that call
all right as we wrap up today's show
man that's that call's gonna stay with
me for a while man just women are
trapped and i hate it i hate it i hate
it all right just wrap up today's show
oh this is kelly's favorite song is it
your favorite song of all time
not necessarily my favorite
but it's one that i really really really
really like the whole album is
phenomenal
it's some song back in the 90s from the
group called tonic
how grateful i mean how how appropriate
now that we're having ending the show
with drinking this is a song by tonic
or by whiskey or by whatever
james
is tonic is that that's water isn't it
you could have tonic by itself and it
doesn't have alcohol we're good
tonic's the
bystander song by tonic it's called if
you could only see it was written back
in the 90s back when bands just played
telecasters and looked at the floor and
sang
and it goes like this
if you could only see the way she loves
me then maybe you would understand why i
feel this way about her love and what i
must do
if you could only see how blue her eyes
can be when she says
when she says she loves me well you've
got your reason you've got your lies and
you've got your manipulations they cut
me down to size saying you love me but
you don't you give your love but you
won't if you could only see the way she
loves me
then maybe you would understand
why i feel this way about this love and
what i must do
y'all realize how ridiculous this is
right here on the john dalone show